welcome witches I'm your hi hostess
Liana Galera and this is the witches
council et's spellbinding series that's
completely devoted to the chilling
Adventures of Sabrina in each episode
I'll be breaking down the biggest
questions and topics from season one of
the dark Netflix drama while also
bringing you exclusive interviews and
answers from Brina herself
Kiernan Shipka and the rest of the
enchanting cast it's not the the classic
Sabrina remember so this yeah it's still
quite family-oriented but it's really
dark Sabrina Spellman
but these are desperate times pencils
out witches because here's a mini
breakdown of what you need to know the
character of Sabrina Spellman was first
introduced in the Archie comics back in
1962 this half-witch half-mortal quickly
became a fan favorite with the readers
and Sabrina was given her own comic book
series then from 1996 to 2003 Melissa
Joan Hart brought the bewitching rolled
to life with her bubbly behavior in
Sabrina the Teenage Witch it's Harvey
and I look like laundry there she fast
forward to 2014
Riverdale creator and showrunner Roberto
aguirre-sacasa resurrected the
spellbinding character for a new graphic
novel about a young sorceress on the eve
of her 16th birthday called
the chilling adventures of Sabrina and
now here we are with this newly
reimagined Netflix series but if you
think you know Sabrina already which
please
the chilling adventures cast promises
that the new show will be casting a
brand new and darker spell on all of you
for the fans out there what do they need
to know about how this Sabrina is
different from Sabrina the Teenage Witch
it's a lot less brightly lit kind of
take on it and you know it's it's the
Sabrina for this age for this time and a
lot of the issues that we're dealing
with the show of really modern issues
catty [ __ ] here no no so nice to see
that this Sabrina is so kick butt she's
such a little feminist why was that
important for you I mean you know me I
love my feminist characters always
always drawn to that kind of content and
yeah I really loved that the show was so
entertaining and fun
and had all these really wonderfully
enjoyable elements but also had this
really nice foundation of being just a
very feminist show led by extremely
powerful wonderful women it's how I like
my urges Ross you're taking on the
iconic role of Harvey kinkle
how are you putting your own twist on
Harvey kinkle usually Harvey had been
depicted to be sort of clueless and
which lets not lie he is kind of
clueless but not adorable not quite as
much as nice nice and a total don't ya
know he's just unaware what I'm
happening yeah he's not door no just
kind of he just is not enough gotcha
can i subpoena I have any of the
actresses from Sabrina the Teenage Witch
reached out to any of you ladies
Caroline Ryan oh yeah
we had she wrote a really gorgeous post
on Twitter when when I had been
announced as playing Hilda and she was
really kind and congratulatory but I was
really honored because she was my
favorite part of the original show
Kiernan do you hope that Melissa Tunes
in I do definitely is she tweeted is she
again she tweeted me and when I when it
was announced that I was gonna be doing
this and I felt good that I got her
blessing young that would be really
closer to him I hope you've enjoyed this
episode of the witches Council
hit that subscribe button and check back
with me for more episodes about
Sabrina's season one journey featuring
exclusive interviews from the chilling
cast and if you're a Riverdale fan don't
miss new episodes of my other series
Sweetwater secrets every Wednesday and
Thursday on e t--'s youtube channel but
for now hit the comments and bewitch me
with your spellbinding thoughts are you
loving the fact that this new Sabrina
series is taking a dark and dangerous
turn what do you think about Kiernan
Shipka as our new Sabrina Spellman and
who else thinks that Ross Lynch is the
perfect Harvey kinkle
thanks for summoning me and I'll see you
soon witches
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]